[Applause]
[Music]
estonia 1991 after more than 50 years of
soviet occupation and communist
dictatorship estonia regained its
independence the legacy of the communist
era for the estonians was as for all the
other countries of the former soviet
union disastrous in 1991 estonian gdp
per capita was less than 3 500 the
equivalent in today's terms of countries
like bolivia or el salvador of course
the worst was yet to come the
disintegration of the soviet bloc was a
hard blow for his member countries and
of course estonia was no exception in
1992 its economy shrank by more than 20
it was time to build a new country model
and visual politics fans this was an
idea that the estonians took very very
seriously while some of the offshoots of
the soviet union such as ukraine
uzbekistan and belarus plunged into
instability crisis and autocracy
estonia's story was completely different
[Music]
today estonia is one of the most
prosperous countries in the world its
potential is immense and its standard of
living is improving all the time in 2020
estonia's price adjusted gdp per capita
approached 40 000 which has already
enabled it to surpass countries like
spain
[Music]
and that is not all the development of
practically all its macroeconomic
parameters beats not only spain but also
the majority of european countries by a
long way for example it's one of the
countries with the healthiest public
accounts in the world and has the
highest rates of entrepreneurship of any
european country in relation to its
population each year more than 20
companies are created for every 1 000
inhabitants that's six times higher than
the eu average
and so estonia has become the nation of
european entrepreneurs something like a
small and yeah let's be honest i see
silicon valley in the very heart of the
european union but having said that the
question is how on earth have they
achieved such an evolution in such a
short time what is the secret behind the
estonian model what are the ingredients
of their success
[Music]
well here as we told you in an exclusive
video on patreon we can highlight
several factors from fiscal policy to
its commitment to technology in addition
among the most important ingredients of
estonian success is its education system
you may not know it and you would never
have imagined it but estonia has the
best education system in europe in fact
it calls itself the education nation but
do you want to know what is so special
about its educational system what
exactly are its most important
characteristics and key aspects if you
do of course you do check this out
[Music]
the how is more important than the how
much
the success of the estonian educational
model is not a matter of opinion it is
something confirmed by all the
institutions dedicated to evaluating the
various educational systems including of
course the pisa report according to pisa
estonia literally leads not in only
europe but the world after singapore
this small baltic country is the top
scorer in all three basic skills reading
mathematics and science
and that is not the end of it let's move
on to some important facts the country
has the world's highest percentage of
high achieving students from lower
income families and it records the
smallest difference in results between
rural and urban environments what's more
they have the lowest rate of students
without basic education just five
percent and one of the lowest grade
repetition rates in the oecd as if all
of that was not enough it also ranks
highest in terms of foreign language
proficiency
[Music]
and so visualpolitik friends here the
social elevator is running at full speed
estonia has overtaken the finnish
education system itself until now the
benchmark for education in europe so how
did they do it and right here i know
what many of you are thinking all right
grant sure sure sure they spend an awful
lot more than all of us on education but
in this case if you said that you'd be
very wrong
[Music]
yes estonia makes significant effort in
education but public spending per pupil
is by far not the highest in the oecd
not even if we adjust spending for the
differences in price and wages in fact
there are many countries with much
higher expenditure per pupil and yet
much worse results do you want an
example well how about get your
visualport bingo cards out spain check
this out
as you can see despite having the best
educational results by far estonia is
far from the country that spends the
most on education per pupil in fact its
level of spending is well below the oecd
and eu averages even taking into account
the price difference which brings us
directly to an idea that i think bears
repeating no politicians spending more
on education is not the recipe for
success if it were that simple it'd be
pretty easy wouldn't it it'd be easy
enough to spend more to get better
results the reality however is totally
different it's not about how much is
spent but above all about how the funds
are used so please politicians and
journalists of all colours and all
parties stop using the money mantra once
and for all
let's take another example iceland
spends much much much more per people
than estonia and i repeat this is even
taking into account the differences in
salaries and prices so if we go by the
political logic that more spending means
better results than iceland should have
a much better education system than
estonia however surprise it's not only
that estonia wins it's the iceland
according to pisa for example is one of
the worst performing countries in europe
spending my friends it's not everything
but having said that and now we know
that it's not just a question of money
what do you say we get right down to it
and dive into the key aspects of the
estonian education system what can we
all learn from them stick around for
that and more puns check this out
[Music]
the pillars of estonian prosperity
okay visualpolitik fans clear your mind
for a while because the educational
model we are going to talk about has
little to do with anything you've ever
seen so far we're going to talk about an
educational model that strangely is not
subordinated to political interests but
the needs of the human capital that the
modern world has including of course the
world of business and entrepreneurship
wait wait wait wait an education system
designed so that students can find a
highly skilled job quickly upon
completion of their studies that seems
almost crazy well yeah that's correct in
estonia education has become one of the
key pillars on which the country's
economic plans hinge now the question
the big question is how exactly does the
estonian educational model differ from
that of other countries well the first
key can be found in independence
independence of both schools and
teachers
[Music]
and you see although in estonia all
schools have to adhere to a framework
program of minimum content set by the
government the application of this
framework is very open and each school
institute or even teacher has a lot of
independence in deciding both the final
educational curriculum and the method
[Music]
and believe me when i tell you that both
school and teachers were the first ones
interested in making all of this work
among other things because of the dual
estonian model of public financing of
education
model what what on earth is that well
let's see in estonia private education
barely exists however despite this
public schools are subject to an intense
model of competition
[Music]
on the one hand the funding of schools
follows a philosophy that closely
resembles the process of market
competition the income that schools
receive is determined by the number of
students they attract the more students
a school gets the more funding it
receives on the other hand the academic
performance and characteristics of each
school are constantly evaluated and the
results are fully public this generates
competitive dynamic of parents willing
to enroll their children in the best
schools and institutes and in turn those
schools attract more students and get
more funding this process also increases
the pressure on the leaders and teachers
of the schools with the worst
performance making them try harder
and that's not all it is no longer just
a matter of the best schools and
colleges being more in demand having
better reputation and more resources but
the good results also guarantee their
survival because one of the great
challenges facing estonia is demography
in the last 15 years the number of
students in the country has fallen by 40
which has forced the government and
municipalities to close the surplus
schools and institutes however it's only
those with the worst results that are
closed so you can imagine the interest
that both schools and teachers have in
improving the results and attracting
more students incidentally at this point
it must be said that the principals and
governing bodies of each school have a
very very high level of autonomy in such
things as for example deciding which
teachers they hire what salaries
teaching staff receive and how they
distribute the funding they receive from
the government
that's right teachers salaries in
estonia are not the same in all schools
nor are they determined by collective
agreement they are decided within the
schools themselves of course the more
funding a center receives the higher
salaries it can pay it's simply the
result of competition what's more this
greater level of autonomy allows each
centre to differentiate itself from
others by specializing in different
areas art economics science and so on
and so forth there are even so-called
elite schools a type of school designed
to be able to develop all the abilities
of the brightest students but that is
not the end of the story teachers are
also subject to higher levels of
competence and more responsibilities
than in other countries
[Music]
for example if students perform poorly
over a long period of time the teacher
may even have to be dismissed but in
order not to have to go that extreme
estonian teachers receive intense
continuous training which allows them to
improve and refresh themselves in terms
of knowledge content or teaching methods
it is an intense and compulsory training
that brings many benefits for example
the adaptation to new technologies
[Applause]
in return teachers have more teaching
freedom and influence in decision making
for example 83 of school principals in
estonia say that teachers play an
important role in tasks such as
designing school policies the curriculum
and teaching methods in this regards
this baltic country is almost double the
oecd average of 42 isn't that amazing
everything absolutely everything in
estonia's educational model is based on
competition and remember that we are
talking about an essentially public
system it seems almost otherworldly now
at this point you may be wondering okay
all right but what exactly does the
school curriculum look like does it have
anything to do with the country's very
high rate of business creation let's
take a look at that now
[Music]
side by side until the final success
we mentioned at the beginning of the
video the estonian educational model is
primarily oriented towards business and
preparation for the world of work for
example representatives of both civil
society and the companies themselves
participate in the design of academic
programs but this is not the only area
of collaboration both secondary and
tertiary education have extensive work
experience programs that allow estonian
students to enter the labour market with
some experience in this regard estonia
has made a very strong commitment to
include work placements and vocational
education which would also be the
equivalent of vocational training and
also in university master's degrees and
we are not talking about the typical
month-long internships these programs
include internships that account for 50
of the training hours but apart from all
the collaboration with companies we can
highlight another very particular
characteristics estonians are obsessed
with equality and the educational face
and i'm not talking about equality in
the sense of making sure that everyone
gets a degree but that everyone has the
same conditions regardless of their
socio-economic environment in other
words equality of opportunities not of
results
that means that in estonia not only is
education paid for by the state
including university but also textbooks
and even the cafeteria students in
compulsory education have free meals at
school in addition all pupils up to the
age of 19 have free health cover as well
as free nurses in primary schools free
routine medical checkups and free dental
care
the fundamental idea is that regardless
of the socioeconomic status they are
born into all students can have the same
opportunities in short competition
specialization integration with the
business world and equal opportunities
in a country with little bureaucracy and
low taxes it's not so bad don't you
think of course not everything is
perfect and while estonia's education
system has proven to be by far the best
in europe today it still has some
challenges too in particular the
shortage of subject-specific teachers
and improving the educational
performance of ethnic russian students
[Music]
but there you have it these are the key
aspects to estonia's educational model
the best educational system in europe
and one of the best in the world one of
the ingredients that has allowed this
country not only to make a huge leap in
prosperity but also to become a
technological leader and a hotbed of
startups the question is do you think
your country should take notes from
estonian success story what do you think
you would like to see in that regard in
your country leave us your comments in
the box below and as always if you like
this video please like it so we know and
subscribe to our channel by clicking on
the little bell down there and by the
way if you like the work we do support
us and join our community on patreon
where in addition to contributing to
visualpolitik you can get exclusive
content as well as periodic gifts and
much more we'll leave you the link in
the description down there all the best
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you